bonsoir nous sommes le 23 avril les 18h
si vous nous rejoignez en direct sur
tvfilm nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actu le
journal de la rédaction il sera question
au cours du prochain quart d'heure de la
web-série on sépare le château de
Versailles autour de la grande guerre
mais aussi et des journées de détection
organisées dans les Yvelines par le club
de football de Laval et puis je recevrai
dans quelques instants des responsables
de la Maison de l'Environnement de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à
Magny-les-Hameaux pour parler et
développement durable et parler de leur
programmation tout d'abord sachez que se
déroule actuellement la huitième semaine
européenne de la vaccination la
couverture vaccinale en France est
encore insuffisante et l'assurance
maladie des Yvelines partenaire de
l'opération a décidé de faire preuve de
pédagogie pourquoi vacciner existe-t-il
des risques rendez-vous sur le site
Amélie santé.fr pour obtenir plus
d'informations et accéder à votre propre
calendrier vaccinal
quatre mini films composés d'archives
inédite et diffusé jusqu'en juin sur
Internet retrace la vie du château de
Versailles entre 1914 et 1918 le premier
épisode est déjà disponible gratuitement
sur le site de l'établissement qui
trouve là un moyen de mettre en valeur
d'une manière originale ces documents
d'archives Yolaine Torres
le château de Versailles à l'époque de
la guerre 14-18 c'est ce que vous pouvez
découvrir à travers une nouvelle web
série de quatre épisodes un pan méconnu
de l'histoire du château proposé par
l'établissement public du domaine
national de Versailles en partenariat
avec la Bibliothèque nationale de France
égalité
pour élaborer les scénaris de cette
série Karine mcgras se plonge dans les
archives du château et mettent en avant
les particularités de l'époque comme la
forte présence de l'armée autour de la
ville l'armée en piétait de plus en plus
sur le domaine de Versailles et avait
besoin de d'espace
soit pour ravitailler les troupes soit
pour installer des différents régiments
et donc il y a vraiment une sorte de
main mise militaire sur sur le château
de Versailles à cette époque du
percement des tranchées dans le parc à
la signature du traité de paix dans la
galerie des Glaces le 28 juin 1919
différents aspects sont présentés ici
par exemple dans les jardins du château
les bassins avaient dû être protégés à
la fin de la guerre l'aviation allemande
menaçait vraiment Paris et la région
des bombardements étaient effectués dans
la région parisienne et donc
les bassins ont été protégés par des
sortes de d'abris qui sont très
étonnants à avoir et dont nous avons un
certain nombre de photographies quatre
mois de travail ont permis de réaliser
ces épisodes de 3 à 4 minutes le premier
est déjà en ligne rendez-vous à la
mi-mai pour découvrir le prochain
les invités de ce 23 avril à présence
Sandrine le flowic la directrice de la
Maison de l'Environnement à Manille les
hameaux et également Flora tout est
chargé de l'action culturelle pour la
Maison de l'Environnement bonsoir à
toutes les deux on va parler avec vous
au développement durable forcément on va
parler de la programmation d'ici à cet
été même un peu plus loin puisque vous
avez déjà défini les grandes lignes
d'ici même là la fin de l'année civile
mais on va commencer par cette
exposition la transition écologique une
exposition interactive autour de
l'écologie aujourd'hui et puis de
l'écologie de demain aussi alors cette
transition écologique on va avoir
rapidement les images de cette
exposition d'ailleurs ça se définit
comment c'est quoi la transition
écologique alors en fait la transition
écologique permet justement d'atteindre
le développement durable donc il s'agit
à la fois de dresser un constat des
ressources naturelles aujourd'hui parce
que finalement les utilisent énormément
pour satisfaire nos besoins dans nos
modes de consommation donc le visiteur
de l'exposition peut dresser ce constat
et puis trouver des solutions pour
changer les comportements et avoir un
comportement éco-citoyen à travers
différents éco-gestes le but de
l'exposition c'est de rendre tout ça
très accessible dès 8 ans
à partir de 8 ans mais il y a plusieurs
niveaux de lecture donc les lycéens ou
les collégiens peuvent aussi venir la
visiter
on peut organiser des visites en groupe
ou en accès libre pour les familles
et puis ce qui a été très intéressant
c'est que l'exposition nous propose des
petits modules sous forme de table
thématique avec des manipulations donc
par exemple un enfant pourra découvrir
la quantité d'eau consommée par un
français un européen ou quelle est la
quantité d'eau consommée pour fabriquer
un cahier en tournant des robinets ou
voilà différentes propositions
différentes manipulations justement avec
les enfants c'est de les mettre en
situation de les faire manipuler vous
avez déjà des retours quels sont un
petit peu les retours des enfants ils
sont forcément il y a une première
partie un petit peu ludique on joue un
petit peu avec tout ça mais est-ce que
le message derrière passe oui tout à
fait le but c'est vraiment de de
conclure aussi avec eux sur les
solutions
qu'ils peuvent trouver eux tout ce
qu'ils peuvent tout ce qu'ils peuvent
faire chez eux ou à l'école ou dans la
ville pour permettre cette transition
globalement le message passe bien et
au-delà de cette exposition parce que
c'est pas la première fois que la Maison
de l'environnement se penche sur ces
différentes thématiques mais vous avez
le sentiment que les jeunes générations
arrivent à on va on va on va faire un
changement vraiment de société
aujourd'hui et en tout cas ce que le
message passe aussi auprès des plus
grands est-ce qu'ils arrivent à faire
changer le comportement des parents par
exemple mais c'est ce que j'allais
exactement vous dire c'est qu'en général
les outils pour les plus jeunes sont en
général très utilisés par les plus
grands qui ont à ce moment-là l'occasion
de pouvoir interagir se poser des
questions et enfin je veux dire un peu
naïvement en tout cas ils sont en
général aussi friands que les plus
jeunes et c'est un outil effectivement
qui s'adapte aussi très bien à une
visite d'adultes sur des questions de
société parce effectivement comme vous
le rappeliez il y a un énorme enjeu à
l'heure actuelle la transition
écologique on en entend beaucoup parler
mais finalement concrètement c'est pas
très bien à quoi c'est un quoi ça
correspond et là c'est l'occasion de
pouvoir expérimenter sur différents
thèmes quels exemples de gestes on peut
donner ce soir aux gens qui n'ont pas vu
l'exposition des choses à faire par
exemple sur la thématique sur l'eau tout
simplement ne pas gaspiller l'eau des
gestes simples que les enfants
retiennent bien éteindre le robinet
quand on se brosse les dents quand on
sait savoir
l'autre pluie pour arroser les plantes
ce type d'appétitivité à cet atelier
interactif il faut s'inscrire quels sont
les modalités c'est très simple de venir
la visiter en accès libre
tous les jours du mardi au samedi de 14h
à 18h ou en groupe il suffit de réserver
auprès de la Maison de l'Environnement
il y a des médiatrices sur place on va
parler des autres rendez-vous aussi à
venir à la Maison de l'Environnement et
déjà décevant vendredi le 25 avril il y
aura une projection projection d'un
documentaire mouton 2.0 c'est pas un
film d'anticipation futuriste c'est une
réalité très concrète et c'est autour de
ces moutons qui aujourd'hui et on
l'obligation au niveau européen d'être
pucées badgé pour être suivi plus
facilement effectivement et donc ce film
pose des questions sur les modes
d'élevage sur les modes de traçabilité
des animaux et finalement sur les modes
de production là évidemment c'est le
mode de production de la viande et donc
en fait c'est un film qui va être suivi
d'un débat et on a aussi une personne du
parc naturel régional de la Haute Vallée
de Chevreuse qui sera là aussi pour
pouvoir répondre au public échanger
essayer de questionner en fait un petit
peu ce mode de production peut-être
aussi informé le public parce que je
sais pas vous mais moi je savais pas que
les motos étaient pucés donc c'est
l'occasion de découvrir le coulisses de
ce qu'on mange de nos assiettes on voit
quelques extraits de ce documentaire et
on va écouter à présent les différents
intervenants au cours de la
bande-annonce les réalisateurs seront
présents d'ailleurs vendredi pour le
débat qui suivra la projection à la
Maison de l'Environnement
nous on a fait tout ce qu'il faut au
niveau sanitaire alors ça c'est le côté
des pouvoirs publics et après bien sûr
comme partenaire il trouve des
entreprises qui demandent que ça vendent
plus vendre des vaccins avant tout ce
qu'on veut j'ai pas choisi ce métier
pour avoir des des brebis avec des
boucles électroniques qui vont passer
qui vont faire bip qui vont s'afficher
dans mon ordinateur etc
de Bruxelles ça va très bien nous
apprendre comment mener un troupeau et
ça on veut pas se laisser faire parce
que notre troupeau c'est notre vie quoi
c'est un peu corps à comparer mais c'est
comme des enfants quoi
c'est la volonté de la contrôle total là
c'est pour les bêtes mais aussi
je pense que mentalement ça veut dire
contrôler tout quoi y compris la société
quand même on est parti pour un combat
quoi c'est pas juste un métier quoi
c'est un combat
documentaire projeté donc vendredi à la
Maison de l'Environnement présence des
réalisateurs il y aura un débat qui
suivra dans vos locaux on se projette un
petit peu sur la suite du programme on
regarde un petit peu ce qui va être
proposé à la Maison de l'Environnement
la prochaine thématique ce sera
naturellement c'est le thème des
prochains rendez-vous qui seront
proposés à partir du mois de mai oui
voilà donc c'est une thématique qui est
très générale deux questions qui aborde
les questions environnementales à la sur
la nature et qui s'appuie sur la Fête de
la Nature qu'un événement national le
thème cette année c'est vieille branches
herbe folle et jeune pousse bon ça va je
l'ai bien mis dans l'ordre qu'un thème
assez rigolo qui permet en fait de
questionner voilà plein de plein de
choses à la fois donc nous on traite à
travers des ateliers pour les enfants
des installations à travers des balades
à travers vraiment plein plein de choses
et un grand temps fort sur le week-end
du 24 et 25 mai
et un village des plantes le 25 mai un
village des plantes ça consiste en quoi
alors pour nous un village des plantes
c'est pas un village où on trouve plein
de plantes cultivées c'est pas ça tout à
fait c'est à dire dans le c'est vraiment
un lieu de convivialité un moment de
convivialité ou au sein de la Maison de
l'Environnement on accueille plein de
partenaires qui présentent justement ou
des ateliers ou des projets qui sont en
train de faire autour de la nature et de
des plantes en fait ça c'est pour les
prochaines semaines prochain mois et
puis si on regarde encore un petit peu
après même après les vacances vous avez
déjà défini les grandes lignes d'ici à
la fin de l'année bah oui on a déjà
plein de temps forts et donc donc c'est
très bien un programme qui qui s'annonce
déjà très chargé avec mi-septembre les
Journées européennes du patrimoine c'est
le thème cette année c'est patrimoine
naturel Patrimoine Culturel donc c'est
on est en plein dedans donc c'est une
thématique très intéressante et après à
partir de début octobre on a la Fête de
la Science avec un cycle sur les
mathématiques qui c'est qui se déroulera
en fait d'octobre novembre et décembre
et on va accueillir une grande
exposition sur les mathématiques
matissim dont on parlera prochainement
on aura l'occasion effectivement
d'évoquer ça sur le plateau du 7 8
l'actu on est bientôt au mois de mai on
arrive au milieu de l'année presque quel
bilan vous faites de la fréquentation ça
marche plutôt bien oui nous on est
toujours très contents parce qu'on a en
plus tenté des nouvelles expériences
cette année en faisant des actions
notamment pour des lycéens avec des
conférences qui ont accueilli énormément
de personnes je pense notamment à Claude
et Lydia Bourguignon on a eu 400
personnes et des voilà et des choses
plus intimistes mais sur des thèmes
aussi plus difficiles peut-être
notamment sur l'AVC donc on est on est
content de cette saison et on est
content de poursuivre merci à toutes les
deux d'être venu donc nous parler de
votre travail à la maison de
l'environnement et puis on le rappelle
cette exposition interactive sur la
transition écologique et à partir de 8
ans et ce sera jusqu'au 21 mai si vous
voulez la découvrir merci donc à toutes
les deux rencontres à présent avec deux
photographes amateurs membres du Photo
Club de Saint-Hilarion ils se sont
donnés pour mission d'immortaliser
l'évolution de la nature au Jardin de
Cocagne ces jardins où les salariés sont
en réinsertion ou les adhérents peuvent
se procurer des légumes bio chaque
semaine Olivier Maniscalco et le dis-moi
pour ce reportage
oh c'est terrible on n'arrive pas à
avoir les bonnes couleurs
observer et capturer notre environnement
au fil des saisons c'est la mission
comme il l'appelle que Christian et
Jean-Pierre membre du Club Photo de
Saint-Hilarion se sont donnés le semi
puis la pousse et enfin les légumes et
fruits arrivés à maturité c'est cette
chronologie agricole qui illustrera leur
travail et l'étape du jour c'est le
jardin de la ferme de bulloyer à
Magny-les-Hameaux j'ai pas mal de photos
de semis qui a sous l'essai encore on a
vu des salades qui étaient semées
plantées ou qui attendent la pousse ma
foi mais c'est surtout bon je travaille
de la terre encore qui est là il est tôt
ça démarre
on prend plusieurs prises de vue quoi
sous différents angles
peut-être différentes sélections de
l'appareil photo de vitesse enfin
sensibilité ISO quoi que ce soit chez
soi on retraite ça pas mal et on a quand
même beaucoup de déchets il faut pas
croire pour une photo bien réussie il y
a beaucoup de déchets
ouvriers sous les serres humidifiées
arbres fruitiers le long des murs de
pierre ou potager en permaculture les
occasions d'immortaliser la nature ne
manquent pas il faut pourtant trouver le
détail qui accrochera l'oeil on y voit
photos il faut regarder l'image l'image
c'est la présentation ça présentation
les objets tout ça pour pour ne pas
faire pour ne pas avoir le regard qui
glisse parce que si un regard glisse sur
une photo tu es nul c'est pas la peine
mais au contraire là où petit truc qui
accroche ça c'est une bonne image waouh
le travail du club va continuer tout ce
printemps les photographes exposeront
ensuite dès le premier juin au Jardin de
Cocagne et à la ferme de grande maison à
Magny-les-Hameaux
15e de la Ligue 2 en football le stade
Levallois a envoyé ses recruteurs dans
les Yvelines afin de procéder à un
repérage des futurs talents du ballon
rond footballeur professionnel un métier
qui fait toujours rêver les plus jeunes
à peine à peine si semaine du début du
Mondial Anthony Rey chez Jonathan Wilman
ils observent 17 chaque Pass chaque
contrôle de balle au bord du terrain les
recruteurs du Stade lavallois préparent
l'avenir si le club effectue la majorité
de ses recrutements en Mayenne ou dans
les Pays de la Loire il s'exporte de
plus en plus dans le Bassin parisien et
pour la première fois ces chercheurs de
talents se déplacent sur les terrains de
Trappes si l'individualisme prime à tous
les niveaux du football actuel ils sont
d'abord là pour repérer un joueur
généreux et intelligent la première
chose qu'on va rechercher l'intelligence
du joueur la deuxième c'est forcément sa
technicité et la troisième donc un petit
peu tout ce qui est dans son sens de la
créativité même si sur certaines
situations le dribble c'est ce qui nous
fait rêver c'est ce qui nous fait lever
quand on est en tribune
mais il faut qu'il soit utilisé au bon
endroit au bon moment
âgé de 14 ou 15 ans c'est 27 John
footballeurs rêvent tous un jour de
fouler une pelouse de Ligue 1 pour les
recruteurs c'est la période idéale pour
repérer les talons qui pourront intégrer
demain leur centre de formation une
étape capitale ou le club formateur fait
office d'agent ça c'est du travail qu'on
fait généralement dans l'ombre parce que
généralement quand les clubs pro
s'intéressent aux enfants faut d'abord
bien baliser de terrain parce que les
parents faut les préparer à ça parce que
quand on a un top qui sollicite en
enfance ça va mais quand on commence à
avoir trois quatre clubs ça commence à
être un peu un peu délicat après trois
matchs d'observation 5 jeunes ont été
repérés mais pour eux le chemin ne fait
que commencer les élus vont être invités
par le Stade lavallois participer à un
stage de trois jours à la mi-mai en cas
de recrutement lorsqu'un jeune signe un
contrat professionnel son club formateur
perçoit une indemnité
merci de nous avoir suivi ce journal et
maintenant terminé vous pouvez le
retrouver comme toutes nos précédentes
éditions sur le site internet de tvfils
excellente soirée et à demain jeudi pour
une nouvelle édition locale